le parc zoologique de thoiry organisé ce
dimanche 16 septembre l'une des cours
civiles noise est plus originale de
l'année un 10 km dans les allées du parc
au milieu des animaux de la savane pour
cet événement plus de 1500 coureurs se
sont inscrits plusieurs semaines à
l'avancé un énorme succès on a été
obligé d'arrêter les inscriptions il ya
déjà trois semaines parce qu'on était
arrivés à la limite de capacité qu'on
avait prévu 1500 dossard ce qui fait de
ce premier événement un des premiers
événements sportifs des yvelines pour la
première fois au niveau sportif les
coureurs l'ont pas eu le temps de faire
du tourisme à 100 % malgré la proximité
avec les animaux les organisateurs
avaient concocté un parcours avec du
rythme dans des espaces verts c'est
intéressant c'était comme un un petit
trail couteau qu'une course à pied avec
des dénivelés le passage sur la
passerelle
c'était sympa là on a un peu tous les
terrains des bitumes et là on a une
bonne cote au château mais c'est hyper
sympa un moment il ya des marches aussi
pour passer au dessus des lions mais le
plaisir il est vraiment là puis on a
super beau temps donc c'est vraiment
sympa vu le succès rencontré le parc
zoologique de thoiry devrait renouveler
l'expérience l'année prochaine
la course pourrait cette fois-ci
accueillir en plus un semi marathon et
de la marche nordique